el pedido de justicia sin resultado se
marca el primer mes del asesinato de
chirín a bucle el 11 de mayo de la
reportera palestina recibió un disparo
en la cabeza mientras cubría una redada
de las fuerzas israelíes en el campo de
refugiados de yenín para testigos sus
familiares y según la investigación de
la autoridad palestina la periodista fue
asesinada deliberadamente por un soldado
israelí pero en este mes el gobierno de
israel ha negado tener pruebas
concluyentes sobre el origen del disparo
ya ha acusado en varias ocasiones al
ejecutivo palestino de no querer
colaborar con una pesquisa conjunta el
hermano de here in antón awac le ha
reclamado a la administración de joe
biden que intervenga en la investigación
para que alguien se haga responsable del
crimen de su hermana quien también tenía
nacionalidad
estadounidense desde la familia de
shirín creen que eeuu no está haciendo
lo suficiente para que se esclarezca su
asesinato en los últimos días el
secretario de estado antonio blinken
pidió una investigación independiente
pero no fue mucho más allá en paralelo
al yazira de la autoridad palestina han
elevado el caso a ante la corte penal
internacional
el ministro de exteriores palestino
riyad al-maliki entregó los resultados
de las indagaciones al fiscal de la cpi
y demandó una investigación transparente
intangible contra israel para que la
justicia envuelva a la memoria de
sitting